[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily he
doesn't scare me i've seen donald trump
make it nothing michael avenatti can say
will scare me stormy daniels speaks out
days after a guilty verdict from michael
avenatti and jury selection is underway
in the trial of a former police captain
accused of murdering a man who was
texting inside a movie theater plus a
former doctor accused of murdering
dozens of patients it takes
the discretion out of the hands of a
doctor who's at the bedside and gives it
to a lawyer in the courtroom famed
defense attorney jose baez explains his
latest case but first i never assaulted
her in any way at any time and while we
did have consensual rough sex the
disturbing acts and conduct that she
described simply did not occur ellie
dodger's pitcher trevor bauer speaks out
for the first time after prosecutors
announced charges will not be filed in
the sexual assault allegations law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin no charges will be filed against
los angeles dodgers pitcher trevor bauer
after a months-long sexual assault
investigation but while the l.a county
da's office won't seek charges the mlb
investigation is still ongoing
that means bower could still face
suspension from the game as long crime
daily reported bauer became the subject
of a sexual assault allegations last
summer when a woman accused him of
punching and strangling her during sex
the accuser said the relations were
initially consensual but later escalated
she claimed she suffered severe physical
and emotional pain and that photos show
physical abuse bauer maintained that the
relationship was quote wholly consensual
in a statement this week major league
baseball said in part quote mlb's
investigation is ongoing and we will
comment further at the appropriate time
meanwhile bauer himself spoke out
following the news that no charges would
be filed
i'd like to set the record straight on
what actually happened
i had consensual sex with this woman on
two occasions
at my residence in pasadena during which
we engaged
in rough sex
this is something that she brought up
you know we discussed it together and
both agreed to engage in
uh we we established rules and
boundaries and i followed them
um on both occasions she consented
beforehand when we established those
boundaries
she also repeatedly consented during sex
when i asked her multiple times if she
was enjoying herself and if she wanted
to continue and in fact she continued to
direct me as to what she wanted
in no uncertain terms when she left she
certainly
did not look anything like
the photos that were later attached to
her family court declaration and
circulated by her lawyers
to the media
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino and terry
austin matthew with no criminal charges
could bowers still be sued civilly or
end up losing his job the mlb
well he certainly could be he certainly
could be sued civilly obviously we're
talking about different burdens of proof
here but the bottom line is
based on that statement that he made it
appears more like he's going to go after
her
for defamation he made it clear
that the way she looked after this
incident was not the way she looked when
she left his house and that he was
emphatic that the the sex was consensual
and they set boundaries and he
continuously asked her for her consent
uh i wouldn't be surprised if he goes
after her for defamation this guy was
the cy young win award winner he was he
has just signed a contract for 102
million dollars there's a lot of money
on the line here and that might be an
incentive yeah terry let's kind of like
look at what bauer is saying what's your
take on this video does it help or hurt
any potential future litigation
listen i think it's going to help i'm
not usually a fan of these types of
statements but here i don't have any
criticisms first of all this was a
statement not an interview so he knew
what he was going to say that was the
right move and essentially it was seven
minutes that's a good length not too
long not too short and he remained
silent until the prosecution said i'm
not bringing charges that was also the
best strategy and he explained why he
remained silent so viewers don't have to
wonder well why didn't you say anything
and i think the fact that he was in
insult he was emphatic like matt said he
wasn't insulting he was really strong
but not hurting his case and he
basically said people have a right to
bring a claim it's overwhelming evidence
so far based on what we've seen and i
think he did a great job with this
statement all right sounds like an a
plus from the school of terry austin
when it comes to giving public
announcements like that uh we'll see how
this develops as the mlb still has to
give its report in its investigation
also in california baseball news the
trial begins for a former oakland angels
employee accused of giving drugs to the
late pitcher tyler skaggs who died of
overdose in 2019. opening statements
were presented on tuesday in the trial
of former angels communications director
eric k prosecutors say kaye acted as a
drug dealer for skaggs providing him
with drugs that contained ethanol
oxycodone and fentanyl but kaye's
defense paints a different picture
saying skag supply drugs to k defense
attorneys also allege the drugs that
cause skag's death may have come from
matt harvey a pitcher and former oakland
a according to the defense chaos gags
take some drugs he claimed to have been
gotten from harvey kay has pled not
guilty to all charges
and in washington an nfl player is
facing involuntary manslaughter charges
in the death of his girlfriend
washington commander's safety to chaser
everett was driving with his girlfriend
olivia s peters two days before
christmas when he drove off the road
everett hit several trees and rolled
over which sent peters to the hospital
where she later died the sheriff's
office says everett was driving at more
than twice the posted speed limit at the
time of the crash everett has played
with the washington commanders for the
entirety of his seven season nfl career
still ahead on law and crime daily
holland lawyers are selecting jurors for
the case of curtis reeves a one-time
police captain turned accused murderer
the first renowned defense attorney jose
baez takes on his latest case as a
former doctors accused of murdering
nearly 30 patients what bias has to say
about the case right after the break
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back a former ohio doctor will
soon stand trial for the murder of at
least 14 patients on wednesday we heard
from the defendant's attorney famed
lawyer jose baez
baez represents 46 year old william
hussell the man who prosecutors say
prescribed excessive doses of fentanyl
to terminally ill patients in his care
while husel is only charged with 14
counts of murder prosecutors say he
could have killed as many as 27 patients
between may 2015 and november 2018. who
sales wife nurse maria bard is also
accused of administering lethal doses to
patients in december 2018 whoso was
fired from the columbus ohio hospital
where he worked after an investigation
into patient deaths he turned himself
over to the police in 2019 the same day
as an indictment was filed whosoever
claims he was easing the pain of his
patients in their final moments defense
attorney jose baez known for
representing casey anthony and aaron
hernandez spoke with law and crime
network on wednesday detailing what
defense attorneys hope for in a future
jury
i think what we're looking for mostly
are jurors that are going to keep an
open mind
he's received tons of bad publicity and
as you know
when you're charged with murder you
can't
give your side of the story the second
it hits the news uh these things are are
best left for the courtroom and that's
where they're needed to to
be laid out
and there's never enough room for the
facts in the headlines it takes
the discretion out of the hands of a
doctor who's at the bedside and gives it
to a lawyer in the courtroom and i and i
think that's what makes this case so
dangerous for
all
physicians and
and as well as patients and prospective
and future patients down the road
there's not a doctor out there that's
going to risk their
their life much less their livelihood if
they fear that they're going to be
retaliated against and charged with
murder
jury selection is already underway in
who sells trial opening statements are
expected to be presented on february
22nd back to discuss fatal fentanyl
deaths is criminal defense attorney
matthew mangino and terry austin terry
what do you think of the potential
defense in this case could attorney baez
be just what the doctor ordered
well it sounds like attorney bias is
taking my class and when and when not to
make statements he is doing something
right though brian originally the doctor
was charged with killing 25 people now
the judge has dismissed 11 of those
charges and it's mostly because those
others had less than 1 000 milligrams of
fentanyl so he's arguing on behalf of
the doctor that he acted in good faith
that he was just trying to give comfort
care he wasn't trying to kill anyone
these individuals were already
terminally ill so i think he's got some
good arguments and we'll see what
happens i think it'll be interesting to
see what's involved as far as his wife
is concerned she may also face charges
yeah and matthew attorney bae is kind of
focused on the big picture here how
could this case affect doctors and
prescription drugs around the country do
you think we'll see more of these types
of cases
well
depending on how this case turns out it
certainly could be
you know a precursor to what's coming
down the road i mean you know it's
difficult enough to prove a medical
malpractice case and that has caused
doctors to be extremely cautious the
idea now that a doctor could face
criminal charges because of a
prescription that he had written or or
moving above a certain threshold in
court
in case of medication that's going to
have a chilling effect on physicians
across the country uh just as medical
malpractice cases have had a chilling
effect on the way
physicians practice medicine in this
country yeah i'll be interested to see
how this case affects not only ohio but
the entire country of course law and
crime network have you covered in that
updates in this case coming up on law on
crime daily stormy daniel sits down with
dan avers to discuss her former attorney
michael avenatti plus our legal experts
break down the jury selection process in
the curtis reeves trial all that and
more after this
[Music]
welcome back jury selection went into
its third day wednesday in the florida
murder trial of christopher reeves a
former police captain being tried for
allegedly shooting and killing a man at
a movie theater eight years ago reeves
allegedly shot and killed fellow
moviegoer chad olson olson was
reportedly texting on his cell phone
during movie trailers reeves became
frustrated with olsen he says he asked
him to put his phone away then ask the
manager to get involved upon returning
to his seat the argument continued the
whole incident was caught on video
investigators say olson threw popcorn at
reeves that's when he pulled out a gun
and shot olson the same bullet went
through the hand of olson's wife reeves
previously claimed he feared for his
life and shot olsen in self-defense
during a stand your ground hearing in
2017. the judge ruled against his claims
prospective jurors have been asked about
owning a gun and any previous knowledge
of the case on wednesday the panel of
jurors were narrowed down to 52 that
will cut down to 10. in total a panel of
six jurors and four alternates will be
chosen reeves faces a second degree
murder charge and has been on house
arrest since the shooting opening
statements are expected to begin
thursday
criminal defense attorney matthew
mangino and co-host terry austin are
here with us to dive into the trial of
the deadly popcorn terry with rhys
losing the stand your ground hearing
does he have any hope of winning
self-defense how are they different the
two
well listen he could still win but i
doubt it i think he lost a big defense
that he could have had a huge blow to
the case under florida law it's related
to each other there's self-defense
there's the castle doctrine there's the
stand your ground under self-defense you
can use that deadly force if you want to
prevent you know death or great bodily
harm
but you have this duty to retreat under
the castle doctrine if you're in your
house you don't have to retreat under
the stand your ground doctrine you can
be basically anywhere as long as you are
being lawful and in a place lawfully so
losing that argument basically puts him
back to basically just you know
self-defense but he does have a duty
retreat so it's a big argument that he
lost there yeah they say he's got to
retreat i don't know how he wins this
matthew looking ahead to opening
statements we kind of know what the
prosecutors are going to say but what do
you think the defense will argue
well the defense is gonna have to argue
uh exactly uh what
was just discussed that in fact uh this
was reasonable it was he acted with
objective reasonableness which means
that he acted like a reasonable person
would have acted under the circumstances
so he was confronted by an aggressive
person there's some suggestion that
there was a cell phone thrown uh he's an
older uh a gentleman he felt that he was
an imminent danger of death or serious
bodily injury and he acted appropriately
by using lethal force
that's what the defense has to convince
the jury oftentimes self-defense is
subjective and objective he may have
this objective i think it's gonna be
really hard to say objectively he was a
reasonable fear of death or serious
injury but of course we'll see how it
plays out on law and crime network when
we come back hear from stormy daniels
for the first time since michael
avenatti's guilty verdict what daniels
says it was like on the stand when
avenatti grilled her during
cross-examination
welcome back to law and crime daily
attorneys continued questioning
potential jurors in the federal hate
crimes trial for the three men convicted
of killing ahmad arbury father and son
gregory and travis mcmichael along with
their former neighbor william roddy
bryan were convicted in november of
murdering aubry in february 2020. the
mcmichaels chased aubry while armed in a
pickup truck after spotting him running
in their neighborhood brian recorded
travis shooting aubry with a shotgun on
his cell phone the three claimed they
were making a citizen's arrest assuming
aubry was responsible for several
break-ins in the era in the area the
mcmichaels and brian were sentenced to
life in prison plus 20 years brian has
the possibility of parole after 30 years
several potential jurors were excused on
wednesday for believing the defendants
were already guilty or saying they
couldn't look past the convictions at
the state level jury selection is
expected to last two weeks wednesday
morning the judge said the trial would
take about seven to ten days
also in federal court a juror is
dismissed in the trial for the three
officers involved in george floyd's
death the judge let the juror go because
his son is ill
two tao thomas lane and j alexander king
are on trial at the federal level for
allegedly depriving floyd of his
constitutional rights when they failed
to give him medical help or intervene
when their fellow former officer derek
chovin knelt on his neck murdering him
now it's in his third week prosecutors
called doctor vic barata an emergency
physician and toxicologist to testify
wednesday when asked about floyd's cause
of death baracta said he died from a
lack of oxygen to his brain he's a
second prosecution expert to testify
floyd died from being suffocated not
from drugs or heart attack but barato
told the jury the amounts of drugs in
floyd's system were too low to have
killed him king lane and tau also face a
separate state trial in connection to
floyd's death that's set to happen in
june
we're hearing now from story stormy
daniels for the first time since last
week's guilty verdict for daniel's
former attorney michael avenatti last
friday a federal jury found avenatti
guilty of stealing 300 thousand dollars
from daniels out of the advance for her
book full disclosure daniels an adult
film actress whose real name is
stephanie clifford rose to fame when
news broke of her affair with former
president donald trump her memoir full
disclosure detailed the relationship
prosecutors say avenatti used the money
from that book deal to pay employees at
his law firm and for luxury car payments
at the federal trial avenatti elected to
represent himself and even cross-examine
daniels as a prosecution star witness on
tuesday she told dan abrams founder of
the law and crime network that what that
cross-examination was like as her former
attorney and friend poked fun at her
belief in the paranormal
i had to keep reminding myself i'm not
the one on trial here i am the victim
and a witness but i was being treated
like i was being prosecuted
i just can't imagine how that would be
if it was a violent crime or if i wasn't
as used to standing up for myself as i
am you know i live here in new orleans
everybody reads tarot it's not that
weird and he was literally reading off
of the website for the paranormal show
the description of the show i was just
ready for him to like bust out one of my
adult dvd box covers and start reading
off the back out so it says here you're
a nurse well it was that day you know
it's just anything to to just create
drama and
confusion is it a ridiculous question to
ask you who you're angry at today
michael avenatti or donald trump
no not at all i'm far angrier at michael
avenatti
um i only met trump a handful of times
not even he i didn't consider him to be
a friend
uh i didn't have private conversations i
didn't trust him michael aven and he
certainly didn't steal from me um
michael avenatti betrayed my trust in
every way possible he lied to my face he
lied about me he put me on a stand for
five and a half hours and called me
names uh this is a man that
i took him as my date ew like no
no way way way more angry at michael
avenatti because that's a personal
betrayal
avenatti will be a sentence in may and
face the possibility of up to 22 years
in prison
matthew avenatti as i said will be
sentenced uh in just a few months and is
facing 22 years behind bars how long do
you think the judge will give him after
hearing all the facts in this case
well you know brian there obviously are
sentence guidelines and um you know one
of the factors that they're going to
take into consideration is he has this
prior conviction as well uh and he
certainly didn't endear himself to
anybody uh you know taking the reins
from his council to to try the case
himself you know kind of switching
horses in midstream uh going after his
former client uh through rigorous in um
ongoing cross-examination
i think that win him any points in this
case as well so i look at him to get a
significant sentence in this case
now terry what are your reactions to the
case especially after hearing the trial
how it ended and now stormy daniel's
interview with dan abrams
she did an amazing job during that
interview i wish we could have seen how
she reacted during the trial we just got
the reports obviously i'm not surprised
with what happened at the trial where
there's smoke there is fire matthew
mentioned the fact that there are these
other convictions he was convicted in
the nike extortion case in federal court
and sentenced to 30 months in prison
there's that california embezzlement
case where there was a mistrial but he's
certain to face those charges again
there's a state court case in california
where he's facing bank and tax fraud so
i really do believe where there is smoke
there is fire the jury didn't believe
what he was trying to assert as a
defense and frankly they believe stormy
daniels and i understand now having seen
that interview why they believed her
yeah that seems like a pretty large fire
uh well thank you both and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you